everything in the focus study is
supposed to Chloe your mind back to your
stuff people with that before now just
look at this question so your question
one which you know with this fall under
roughly at least what it what does it
look like one would grab that's a great
idea I think what did you do right
before your apt twos we actually did a
string of them altogether we did we did
when you've got lots of data in a table
dot estate what do you see here there
are some graphs I started a statistics
too so this is stuff you've seen before
let's just quickly look at the questions
and then I'll show you my answers so
just to jog your memory like this is not
hardsub okay so top 10 most downloaded
artists a few years back now you can see
they're asking us to come over here add
a column let me zoom in and write each
of these convert them in from scientific
notation why might that make sense have
a look at what BC and D are asking you
why might it make sense for your first
step to be to do this yeah that's right
like have a look at the numbers you've
actually got like as if you're going to
do it to this level of detail I come oh
I really need a really fine ruler okay
you're not going to get this level of
detail they're asking for just two
significant figures because
realistically autograph that you're
gonna hand draw I think that's perfectly
okay so you're going to convert into
scientific notation that's pretty
straightforward then they ask you to put
together three graphs three graphs have
a look at how that information a column
graph start at zero listed up in
billions okay so that's fine
read rule the same column graph but
instead of studying zero
started 25 million now when you
across the look at the data okay the
lowest note in one of the top ten is at
twenty eight point six okay so have a
picture in your head of what that's
going to look like when you raise the
bottom of the axis and then the last
question is instead of using column
graph colon graft or a sector graph tie
them all up
which of the three graphs does not
display the data accurately and then
explain now by the way just as a quick
note um because they just had their rate
receipt and not that long ago these
questions here questions which are like
hey what is he's doing in a messy to
explain justify describe those are
really important in fact I kind of think
they're the most important questions for
the whole thing so I'm gonna give you my
answer for this right now
it's have a look here's what my answer
for question one looks like here we go
okay so what was that first question
again we supposed to do okay so you can
see I've converted over there on the
right and I've got two significant
figures there's the first one there's
the second one and all the way down okay
it's ten to the seven how do I get seven
because I'm County I'm counting up one
two three four five six seven until I
get to about four point that's where the
decimal point belongs yeah
okay so that's fine you can do that all
fairly easily and this is going to be
what you use when you graph so he's got
my guys look like Oh put B and C
together at the same time actually okay
now it doesn't matter if you can read
this or not because they're just honest
named you can see this is my one
starting at zero millions of downloads
so I want to leave all five and I think
that's like four point six seven
whatever it was okay now have a look
compared B and C for me which do you
think is a more accurate representation
of the relative elements B Y B points be
better
yeah very good we looked at this under
misleading graphs if you recall if you
have a look at this one if you compare
this to this it looks like your top
looks like Rihanna has like what four
times as many five times as many sales
as Britney where is actually that's
quite exaggerated this I just pulled out
of the answers because this is this is
what a safety belt looks like just have
a look at where as we are hearing issues
so this sum this sector part here that
represents her when you going to create
the sector graphs you're going to come
to your how are we going to actually
work out what this angle okay so we're
gonna have to divide by 360 because
that's the total number degrees but
maybe just because if I think about you
got the numbers there right what was on
Rihanna's give it to my whole point
something for point a to it okay now
we're gonna have to divide that get that
as a proportion of all of these top ten
offices right how am I gonna work out
how much in total they're gonna do she's
gonna have to add them right I'm just
gonna do a quick estimate because I
haven't calculated um have a look what
do you reckon let's call that 5 plus 4
is 9 13 17 21 I'll round that up 2529
the 538 call it roughly okay
obviously you can get a puppet number
for that okay now what's this gonna be
well the minions will just cancel out
okay so then you get this this is like
how much of the circle
she should have for point out of it
through a video and then the last thing
was as I'm Cindy mentioned a whole set
was 360 degrees right can someone tell
me what this is I'm just going to give
25 because I can't measure i if you have
my protract off you can't really mention
that much detail now 45 degrees is what
I'm estimating what do you think is that
reasonable 45 years thanks all right cuz
I mean keep in mind if I have like a
lion here we're all pretty good at
recognizing our right angle right so if
that's like a right angle there it's
pretty close right and remember I just
punch this number I just estimated so
but you see how I did it I worked at how
much that was divided by the total and
then we're doing 360 degrees because
that's a whole circle okay so that would
be your proportions and you're gonna
have to do second graphs later on now
you compare B and C for me what do you
think of date do you think it's an
accurate representation of the data most
of you say no which is interesting just
interesting because the textbook says
yes now I'm interested as to why people
say no and why people say
seeing the entire like all of the
downloads music leads us to a second
graph does tend to imply this is
everything like it's the home circle
okay
the textbook does say yes though what do
you think is the yes that's part of is
the accurate the proportions are correct
their proportions here are certainly a
lot better than their proportions here
do you agree the important thing is is
the funny thing I didn't you might feel
a bit awkward about this but the HSC
they would have said yes or no provided
you gave one of those justifications
because they're both valid points okay
the important thing is you understand
what this is communicating and I I
personally kind of think I tend towards
I don't know if you guys have seen
graphs like this
it's like he's all these different
sections and then they're like okay
because sometimes all of the bits that
you can't count actually account for a
lot of it right which you'd expect this